well there are scholars who say there is
an Islamic economy and that is
capitalism right and I agree with those
you I am Nick Gillespie with Reason TV
and today we're talking with Mustafa
Akyol
he writes for The New York Times and
he's also a visiting professor at the
Freedom Project of Wellesley College
Mustafa thanks for talking to us thanks
it's my pleasure
okay we are at the international student
for liberty conference so I want to
we'll get to questions about
international students and liberty but
first let's talk about your two books
Islam without extremes what is you know
Makemake the basic case there and do you
see since it's been published is that
argument gaining ground among Muslims
yeah that book is La Mirada extremes
actually had the subtitle which explains
it which which reads a Muslim case for
liberty and basically in that book I
tried to criticize all the
authoritarianism I see in Islamic
countries within Islamic teachings
things like banning blasphemy or
apostasy or forcing people to do certain
practices and I argued against those
again from within Islam background
because these are I mean there are just
as there are many I wanted to say there
are many versions of Christianity even
within a single organization like the
Roman Catholic Church there are many
different Catholicism's
exactly um there is no reason for Islam
to be authoritarian on any level right I
mean I had yeah exactly that's my
argument and we have both when you look
into the Quran you have certain verses
that really vindicate human freedom that
should that declare there should be no
compulsion in religion but there are
other verses you know some medieval
scholars abrogated the liberal verses
with the other ones thinking that you
know they are creating a more high
society where I using no authority and
and when you look at Islamic thought
there are really interesting video
despotic currents that insets I
emphasize liberal values such as reason
so
as individual choice such as pluralism
yeah we'll talk a little bit about that
because this is one of the questions you
hear and particularly in America now you
hear a lot about people saying well
Islam is not like every other religion
you know because you know Islam is
fundamentally incompatible with a
secular pluralistic society because
there is there any reason to to think
that that's true I mean the current
state of affairs in the Muslim world can
give that pessimism salient as well
there is very little freedom in this
world which is true and that's why I'm
Jo arguing against it but what Islam can
be what it is LOM was in the past is a
different discussion interestingly the
same argument was made about Judaism
from the 18th century when Jewish
reformers like Moses Mendelssohn were
arguing that Judaism is actually
compatible with freedom of religion
people like Humana melkunze were saying
no no no Judaism is a religion of law it
has rigid laws unlike Christianity it's
not through your spirit it can never
adopt a free society but actually use
where was you she enlightenment Haskalah
and induced well dealt with very similar
issues and now you have many Jews living
in the West as defenders of a free
society so is the authoritarian Islam er
the the turn to authoritarianism in
Islamic countries is that first off is
it mostly geographical are those types
of countries actually rooted in the
Middle East or in North Africa and is it
fundamentally a modern development is it
coming out of the writings of whether
it's somebody like YouTube or you know
many of the things that the Catholic
Church for instance in the mid nineteen
hundreds had the first Vatican Council
which rejected modernity and it actually
tried to go back to a false but a false
version that they said was traditional
Catholicism that was against capitalism
against you know against modernity
against women's rights and things like
that I mean is authoritarian Islam
actually even modern problems yeah is it
it's a modern development it has been
exacerbated by modernity but by a new
era
immersion of modernity I mean there are
things like a pasta a pasta should be
killed in medieval texture so I'm
dealing with those right so I can't say
medieval Muslim societies were liberal
in the front understand today there were
some liberal maybe proto liberal
currents and I'm trying to revive Road
well what happened in the modern era is
that that tradition got worse because it
combined with the modern state which was
a very centralized you know hierarchical
institution I mean people like sage
could obscure name they referred he's
known as the father of you know the
fundamentals currents we have today he
basically took a lot of things from
Islamic tradition but combined them with
a fascist state right that was the Arab
states by they even they even I mean
secular Arab really admired that right
so well and then he was ultimately was
executed by Abdul Nasser right yeah he
was executed by our abdicate er yeah who
was taking that and creating a kind of
an Arab mentality
the problem is I think when the state is
by definition and Leviathan different
groups try to capture it and Islamists
try to capture it by Islamic arguments
right hence you had this synthesis
called Islamism which became a political
ideology but but they brought
authoritarian sometimes from tradition
but they also admire them in fascism
they said I mean they do the Pakistani
scholar who's also one of the godfathers
of Islamism
he admired the fascist model he said
they just had the wrong idea in this
state we will put his slummy to it so he
got this modern authoritarianism and
combined with that so in my book I tried
to untaek all all these problems and say
well here's how we can Rihanna stand
Islam free from some of the burdens of
the tradition but also free from this
modern modern authoritarianism which
doesn't have to be the only way of model
is well
two quick two questions one quick and
then one a little bit longer so what
what about Islam as its practicing
Indonesia and Malaysia is it would would
a Muslim from Turkey or from Algeria
would they recognize if they were in a
mosque in Malaysia and Indonesia they
were recognized but also they will be
surprised with the difference of
culture they will be surprised with if
the practices would be based mostly
similar but I mean you can go to Africa
like you can see Muslim woman wearing a
clothes that you know her belly is open
for example images Wow
so you know I'm think about for someone
coming from the Gulf area with tea or
like covering the face that is the norm
in Saudi Arabia from Turkey when you
look at from the Balkans even the most
conservative moving just wear a
headscarf
covering the face is too much so yeah
there are different different variations
that if the Islamic world is so diverse
I mean and in opinions are diverse like
if people are asked should we really
stone people for adultery like 70
percent Pakistani say yes in
bosnia-herzegovina which is a Muslim
nation in the middle of the Balkans all
the people who say yes to this is 0.2
percent right according to Pew Research
yeah this is the diversity we does that
mean that Pakistan has a bigger lobby
for stone builders or something that so
makers so which goes to my second
question that kind of capitalism or free
enterprise you hear a lot about how
Islamic kind of that I realized that it
they don't exist but the concept of
Islamic economics and say there are
prohibitions on the charging of interest
or all sorts of things that this makes
it impossible for a Muslim countries
that have a thriving modern economy are
those is is that those sets of laws are
they of relatively recent origin or are
they just so widely ignored that you can
have a functioning free enterprise
economy in a Muslim country well there
are scholars who say there is an Islamic
economy and that is capitalism right and
I agree with those do and because when
you look at the history of Islamic
civilization you see that Islam was born
as a very trade friendly religion how
the Mohammed was a merchant I Ralph yeah
so he has sayings you know venerating
trades when he was asked to regulate
prices in medina he is a famous saying
and says I don't regulate prices God
regulates them which you know some cap
was minded Moses ya know that I think
that's how we got the federal
Reserve so I'm not yeah yeah I mean yeah
constantly I'm gonna comment on that but
so there is a tradition of Islam that
actually values enterprise and trade and
free trade and even how doing the great
Muslim sociologists of the Middle Ages
he actually wrote that the state state
becomes wealthier if there is less tax
and if state is less involved in your
economy so we have that tradition yeah
and that tradition had a few roadblocks
one is the ban on interest as you said
and some of them's are rigid about that
but others including myself would say
well what is really condemned in the
Quran is usury right
whereas which is modern different than a
rational modern banking interest and
that there's and it's you know it's
fascinating just sitting here talking
about this because these all of these
arguments and all of these developments
have exact analogs in western you know
increment down because this was you know
John Milton's father was a usurer or
that's why Jews were moneylenders
because Catholics weren't allowed etc it
would be wonder like well before we
start talking about the book about Jesus
the way that Islam views Jesus yeah I
mean why why don't we get in the united
states or what has to happen to get a
broader sense that islam is not one
thing and that that one thing is
Mohammed Atta flying into the World
Trade Centers well what made those
people 9/11 terrorists or other
terrorist Isis al-qaeda definitive is
that they create a shock and they make
the news right so people hear these
people would be you know horrible
terrorists and they shape an image of
your flock which is very unfair I mean
yes they are a big threat we did not be
naive about trust coming from our usual
qaeda by the way that that source is
coming to us to I mean a sample was
bombed by Isis yeah three times in the
just pass now and I know in the area
yeah you know all of all of the depths
are Muslims as well then I mean did the
people who fight them are also Muslims
on the ground so this is a very small
extremist fanatical strain within Islam
which should be fought which should be
you know taken into consideration for
sure but to extrapolate that to all
Muslims and to say this is what it
probably is it would be the biggest
mistake to do is there a deeper kind of
logic there when when you think about it
a place like Europe a space like Europe
Europe as a concept kind of defined
itself for centuries as the non Turk you
know it was like the Turk at the door we
are holding off the Turk and to by
extension I think a lot of American
culture or English culture what not also
sees Islam you know there's the Crusades
and even though most Americans know
nothing about Islam but they know kind
of like the way we used to be against
the Soviets well we've always been
against Islam does that play into it and
is that that would be a harder probably
harder nut to crack right in terms of
engaging Rhian gauging without this you
know millennial long kind of Twilight
Struggle well first of all I mean very
good point you're making yes there is a
let's say geopolitical tension between
let's say the Orient and the Occident
Braccio and the Occident happens to be
you know so defined by Christianity and
orient defined by Islam the Orient was
defined by Eastern Christianity too so
it's actually a geographical thing yeah
and that's not a little initially I
really do on the other hand you have
other episodes you have in medieval
Spain a culture of current events via
where muslims jews and christians worth
together puzzles or ruling class but
jews prospered and what's the best time
you ever had actually on the modern era
of fully money right ratio but that's
but that data that's the catholics are
still like mad right because I kicked
the Moors out many vintages convert the
Jews who led from the Catholic yeah came
to the Ottoman Empire that's why we have
a Sephardic community channel in
Istanbul who were escaping the
Inquisition so it was not that by
definition muzzles were the liberal one
right it is actually quite no yeah
totally that's one thing the other thing
is that sometimes I mean end up even
that combat like complicacy you have
corporations on the Ottoman Empire and
the French and the Brits went to war
against Russia in the famous Crimean
your exam right and we still have traces
of that in a jumble there's a Florence
Nightingale hospital coming
the British you know taking care of the
patient right and all that so the
history is not black and white but we
tend to see that where it's sometimes
helped us to see that way but we should
see all that not let's talk I mean
that's so fascinating and it's great to
think about now where are the places of
nice negotiated interactions between
Muslims and Christians or Western in
eastern countries however you want to
talk about it but let's talk about your
book about Jesus and how Jesus is
presented in Islamic theology and I mean
so he is one of a you know for
Christianity he's the beginning and end
basically in Islam he is one of several
prophets is that correct I mean what
exact what in his actual standing yeah
you're referring to my new book I think
it has to be Islamic Jesus which came
out a week ago and the top title is how
the King of the Jews became a prophet of
the Muslims right so basically in the
book I am showing what islam teaches
about jesus how the differs from
mainstream Christianity but it have
actually resonates with some heretical
sects in early Christianity some
apocryphal Gospels and there's they're
very intriguing in connection there and
you can understand them from whatever
theology you're looking and you can say
oh one of our heresies influenced the
origins of Islam Muslims can say our
beliefs were already there within
Christianity so they can see it as an
indication I'm not taking aside so but
but I'm also going against some of the
biases of Muslims against Christians and
Christians against Muslims like for
example the Quran generally against the
concept son of God is actually denounced
concept and of course how that is Jesus
is defined in Christianity but when you
read the Quran carefully you see
something the Quran is actually
condemning Arab notions Arab policy ism
where you have a father and a wife and a
son and a child and you have sexual
relationship between so it is condemning
a carnal didi with a family which was
the Arab pagan notion it was related at
the time which is not exactly what
Christians obviously bring when they
speak of Genesis so maybe Muslims can be
a bit more understanding
to the concept of Sun or God we're
Christian Judah so that's for example
one perspective I bring so I'm trying to
bridge the theologies a little bit
finally I'm the eyelid chapter which I
think may gather some interest sighs
those types of what Jesus can teach
Muslims today and there I'm saying to
fellow Muslims
hey listen okay we don't think Jesus is
Son of God of course like Christians we
see it as a prophet like one of the
greatest prophets like Moses Abraham a
figure like that but then what we learn
from Jesus what does you tell us Carrie
we should still think and there I say
what Jesus says to fellow Jews at the
time of history line is is a message
that we need today because he criticized
use for being of his time and the
Pharisees especially he was used himself
to to be too legalistic to just be very
obsessed about the minor details of the
law religious law the halacha but
forgetting some moral principles behind
it you know he opposed the stoning of a
woman in writing the one without the sin
should cast the first stone well that
kind of perspective is needed I'm saying
with us Muslims today because we have a
Pharisee like attitude right no no then
was like in one of the parables where
you know a person doesn't help somebody
whose donkey has fallen into a ditch
because it's a SAP at the Sabbath and
Jesus is like what we do you know what
is wrong with you of course you would do
that of course we didn't and he says the
Sabbath is made for certain the summit
is made for men not men made for this
Alex and I have a line I'm saying the
Sharia is made for Ven not meant for the
Sharia so Islamic law should not be
something that oppresses us it should be
something to protect us from from Ebola
is there something that is an analog of
kind of the golden rule of do it I do
onto others as you would have them do
unto you so that you're replacing a long
list of particular things don't do this
don't do this do this don't do this with
that kind of principle is there an
Islamic principle that kind of would
move from a very rule rule bound
literal set of implications to a kind of
more
voltage there is actually I mean decides
the discussion on Jesus there is a
tradition in Islam called mikasa which
means intention so this was emphasized
by medieval scholars like a mom shot to
be who lived in Spain by the way the you
know bright spot there and he said he
look into Islamic law and he said all
this plumbing law actually is about
protecting five values and he listed
them as protection of religion life
property intellect and lineage now some
modern Muslim thinkers say if you look
at these five values today they are
better protected in Canada different
audio if you are Iran so Islamic
intentions are subject so there's a big
gap there between an intention visible
so that is there I think Jesus
emphasizes most powerfully in the
history of world religion and I think
therefore I refer to that mikasa that
intentional tradition in Islam and I'm
just also bringing a perspective from
Jesus as a prophet of Islam as Muslims
with who really emphasizes issue in a
very inspiring way so let's look at him
and get an inspiration for some reform
and change in our Muslims I have a final
question for you as a lot of people in
the u.s. keep saying you know what what
Islam needs is a reformation and
obviously Islam has actually gone
through various Reformation including
some that brought it to its current
point apart from that or regardless of
that is if a country if a major Islamist
country say Iran or Saudi Arabia
actually Falls from within from a
popular revolution that kind of pulls it
down is that the type of thing that
might jump start a wider discussion with
it Islam and also you know from
non-islamic countries where we can start
to reengage on a more fruitful level I
think those comparisons between Islam
and products and information are not
right to the point
right because the Protestant information
was a revolt against a centralized
Catholic Church in Islam we don't have
that right we actually have a very
decentralized
that's why that comparison doesn't
always hold what we need is the
Enlightenment not the products and
information right but what not not
Luther but John Locke Rudd John Stuart
Mill you know that kind of enlightenment
tradition that brought reason and treat
him to the table and which was not
hostile to Christianity I mean some
aspects of their life in the war but for
example John Locke wasn't he right the
contrary there's no reinterpreted
Christianity and I think didn't wrote
more about the book of Revelation exact
talking about nature because god they're
compatible so the end of things we have
those efforts you know we have you know
chat efforts towards an Islamic in
alignment here and there in Malaysia
there are this progressive group in
Indonesia there's this among Arabs
there's this so and I personally I'm
connected and I know these people and so
there is an effort it's just it's a big
battle there's no it's not going to be
won overnight I mean John Locke made
some liberal arguments which brought
look too wishy-washy for many Christians
every time they wanted a bio to call on
him he was coming after a hundred years
of you know physical fights exactly and
after a very painful lesson some
Christians came to those I think good
good solutions and I think we are going
through those pains in Islam today do
you do you think if if a country like
Saudi Arabia you know which it was kind
of in a precarious place or Iran there's
always a lot of tumult and possibilities
coming out of there if one of them
collapses and not from a CIA coup and
neither ameno Donald Trump making
America great again with that hat would
that be helpful to discussions about
Islam and its role in kind of the modern
world it may or it may not
I mean the political the political
changes do not necessarily change the
theology right away
I mean collapse of Saudi Arabia I can I
mean I'm not a big fan of Saudi regime
or a run for sure but it can lead to
this integration and some civil war and
now you will have a different problem or
example the Assad regime of tyranny and
now you have in Syria maybe even worse
than what was before so this idea that
you should change the political
structure and ultimately it will
influence religious views is not always
I think relevant you should have good
models an example Tunisia is one for
example I would think of Turkey in the
past
but unfortunately I'm not referring to
turkey that much anymore is there an
example for complicated reasons you have
Tunisia in the Arab world as a country
where you have this limits and securest
agreeing on a basically liberal
framework a constitution for example so
and I mean authoritarian regimes are
problem in themselves when they collapse
that can trigger something good that can
trigger a chaos where in civil war as
well
what is though may be happening is that
in Iraq and Syria there's obviously a
sectarian civil war today and just
people are killing each other because
they're Sunni or Shia
and some some I think wiser Islamic
thinkers in Turkey have been saying that
maybe that's why sector ism is needed
yeah
because sectors in came as a Western
import like a it was refused by most you
know comprises religious conservatives
but now they co2 capture the state
Sunnis and Shia are killing each other
maybe we need a secular state precisely
to avoid problems like those disasters
like this and that's how Christians came
to the solution of the secular state
basically so I think we are going
through a some processes that
Christianity went through Jewish and
litem is I think very important though
because I see more similarities between
Judaism and Islam in terms of being law
based religions and I think Islam is in
a place that these other judeo-christian
a Christian you know Sisters of Islam
were a few centuries before and there's
no reason to say that you know it will
be always like this and I think we are
in a crisis at the end of which that our
understanding of Islam may emerge and
I'm personally trying to push for that
good well we will leave it there we have
been talking with Mustafa actual he is
right for the New York Times he's also a
visiting professor at the Freedom
Project of Wellesley College your most
recent book is the Islamic Jesus yeah so
that which sounds fascinating thank you
so much thank you my pleasure for recent
TV I'm Nicolas ting
[Music]